are in the world right now gas prices  soaring and some car owners maybe you've  made the switch yourself to electric  power but that can be an expensive  change when california companies helping  drivers take that leap switch vehicles  as you see here specializes in building  clean cars and it's all done through a  kit you basically build it yourself  business they say is booming ceo peter  oliver initially only sold about three  kits a year but now he ships out about  five a month  is this like an ikea for  like electric cars well  yeah but the instructions are readable  would you buy his car the kits come with  everything including a tutorial because  you don't want to try and build that  with no guidance in some cases students  spend a semester building them as well  they get to learn about cars the final  product is basically an exoskeleton it's  a chassis and they can cruise down the  highway